[音楽]
あっこんにちははじめ社長です
あの
ポストが入ってるんですけどあの
質問コーナーやりすぎた説浮上しております今節またちょっと質問コーナーポイントが
多分出ると思うんですけど
おぺシャルゲストと質問コーナーちょっとやりすぎた雪が私の中で浮上しておりまして
なんかそうそうちょっと寝方子達と変えて別能年が方法でもっと視聴者の皆様とかと
行動がを作れたらなあとちょっと私考えましてそこで私思いました
誰かを応援したい応援動画避けてみたいな考え先のが出てきまして
まあこういう世の中なんでひょっとしたらすごい困ってたりなんか世界に絶望して窮地
に立たされすごくメンタル的に困っている人と落ち込んでる人がいるかもしれないなぜ
で早世してみたいことがあるんだけどもそれに向かう勇気がないですとがあるけど
すごい不安だそう
の人がきっとね今年は特に多いような気がするんですよ側が私思いました
長毛なかなかデコ素直に素直に応援してくれる人っていないんで私初めて長が応援団長
となり電力であなたを応援しましょうという動画でございます
はいというわけでこの動画のコメント欄に応援してほしいことを書いてくださいどれ
ぐらいけれど
わからないんですねちょっと全文読んでコメント欄で何か見つけて応援してほしいこと
とか勇気が出ないことかを待ってることがあったらこう私は高校時代応援団長だったん
ですキー団の効いたの応援団長だったこの映画が全力で全力でも応援させていただき
ます
絶対電気出ると忘年わからんけどござるなんかも質問コーナーなんで
俺のことみんな知ってんじゃん俺のこと知ってるんでなんかこう
逆に皆さんの曲に皆さんの内部困ってることとか応援してほしいこととかめっちゃ綺麗
なんですけども例えば
テストが心配です応援してくださいとか明日ないが好きな人に告白しますけどね応援し
てくださいとかもう名前付きで私はしっかりと応援させていただきましたおよびでこの
動画の子
メントランでお待ちしておりますとか山とかな10月の僅かまで10月の初回一杯は
エッドコメント見てると思います単位で遊んだの
きっちり決めるとなんか
大体それぐらいまでに書いておいてくれると多分いますなるべく大勢の人を全力で応援
させていただきたいと思います俺気付いたんです
俺人を元気づけるかなって
気持ち浮気者じゃないんですよねちょっとをロイド年が質問コーナーじゃない何か新た
な手段としてちょっとやってみたいなと思いますねあのどんなことでもいいですとして
もコーナー3がてふざけるようなコメントもあるかもしれませんがそれでもいいんです
すべてをの動画を見ている応援して欲しい皆さん是非応援させてくださいって言うけど
この動画のコメント欄でお待ちしておりますもう
あなたの応援団所の権限で大谷得意なんであの
ぜひまだしください名前とかも書いちゃってんで自分の名前とか何々君何の音ちゃん
頑張ってとかは全然なんでもいいんでもコメント何でもいいです
もう多いじゃなくてもいい
それを困るけど何でもいいでぜひ皆さんのコメントお待ちしております
[音楽]
bloo